on a un piége les voilà donc ça c'est un
pied qui donnera rien qui va dépérir en
fête ce mercredi 14 avril cet
agriculteur de neauphle le vieux
constate les dégâts sur ses champs avec
les températures négatives de ces
derniers jours il a perdu entre 30 et
50% la production d'orge et de colza
cause de ce choc thermique
ce qui a fait du mal en fait c'est qu'on
est on a eu trois jours à plus de 25
degrés et deux jours après on était avec
deux jours à -7 donc une amplitude
thermique quasiment de plus de 30 degrés
d'écart et ça ça pardonne pas les
plantes étaient repartis le gel est
arrivé et ça a été un coup de massue en
fait pour les plantes cet agriculteur
avait déjà connu un épisode semblable au
printemps 2010 est cette année encore il
n'a pas pu utiliser des techniques
antigel dans ses cultures et si nous en
grandes cultures on peut absolument rien
faire sert qu on est à la merci du temps
à merci de la sécheresse merci des
grands froids merci de la merci des
grandes pluies
donc on peut rien faire c'est là qu'ont
subies ont subi simplement cette
exploitation n'est pas la seule à avoir
été touchés sur le territoire mais dans
certains secteurs le gel a été plus
ravageur plus tôt ce qui est toute la
zone où dans rambouillet ça a été un
petit peu plus froid que tout ce qui est
plein au niveau touahri marque ça a été
quand même un petit peu enfin à 2 degrés
après cet agriculteur ne peut pas encore
quantifier de façon définitive les
dégâts il faudra encore attendre une
petite semaine notamment sur les
cultures céréalières
les températures devraient quand elle
commencé à remonter ce week end